après sept mois de fermeture les salles
de loisirs indoor entre voit la lumière
au bout du tunnel
depuis mercredi elles peuvent de nouveau
accueillir du public
un vrai soulagement pour leurs
propriétaires qui n'ont qu'une envie
nous divertir lucas chopin a testé deux
nouvelles activités
deux idées de sorties pour les week-ends
à venir regarder
[Musique]
vous l'avez compris nous avons testé
pour vous un circuit de karting
interactif inspiré de l'univers de mario
kart
une avant-première pour t'aimer tour
puisque cette activité ne commence que
ce week-end après un an d'attenté
le gérant est véritablement soulagé nous
sommes allés à sa rencontre
l'actuelle carte c'est un concept de
loisir de karting avec réalité augmentée
vous roulez à à bord devrait karting
électrique sur une piste qui est vidéo
projetée depuis le plafond vous roulez
sur des cases bonus vous récupérez des
bonus avait initialement ouvrir en
juillet 2020 et on va enfin ouvrir
pratiquement avec un an de retard
battle carte n'ayant pas été en activité
avant la crise sanitaire il est très
difficile pour son gérant d'obtenir des
aides mais pour s'en sortir les six
salariés de l'entreprise compte sur le
fait que battle cars soit la seule
activité du genre en france
autre lieu autre activité nous voici à à
james à saint cyr sur loire pour
pratiquer le lancer de hache
après sept mois de fermeture le lieu
rouvre seulement à ses gérants sont
impatients de voir du monde
[Musique]
hb games l'activité s'est stoppée après
seulement quatre mois pour fêter la
réouverture les gérants propose de
nouveaux objets a lancé comme des
shurikens une façon de marquer un
nouveau départ après une période
compliquée c'est une période très
difficile de
savoir si on allait survivre ou si on
allait mettre la clé sous la porte
sept mois c'est un chiffre d'affaires
est une jeune entreprise c'est très
difficile même derrière nous masquons a
le sourire de rouvrir nos portes et
d'accueillir nos clients ça nous touche
énormément
[Musique]
jusqu'à la fin du mois les salles de
loisirs indoor est limitée à des jauges
de 50% mais dès le 1er juillet
l'activité pourra reprendre normalement